this is from freshman i told you
that cool you're going to get married
but you have for 50 she has a divorce
you're gonna have to pay alimony 90
chance that you're gonna have to pay
alimony 90 chance that you're not going
to be able to see your kids and it's
going to go to the man and you're also
going to have to give up 50 of your
money would you still get married
okay so do you see what's wrong with
this right from the get-go
doomsday you go into any situation and i
don't care what it is you go into any
situation in life looking at what could
go wrong the way he's looking you will
never do it
so i thought about a couple of things i
was like hmm looked up a couple of stats
43 of first-year drivers are involved in
car crashes it's a pretty high number
you gonna not get in a car
is that going to be your decision oh
there's too much against me i can't do
that no you're not you're going to get
in your car you're going to be
responsible you're going to put your
seatbelt on you're going to look both
ways
you're going to pay attention you're not
going to be on your phone and you're
going to enjoy that ride
you're going to put your windows down
you're going to feel good about it
you're going to sit back you're going to
feel empowered all of those things
2021 3.2 million people were treated in
emergency departments for sports
injuries this was interesting exercise
cycling basketball were the most
frequent ones this is from the cpsc
you're not going to play sports
you give up that basketball you're not
going to do it no
you're going to stretch right
you're going to stretch on the sidelines
you're going to try to be physically fit
so you're mobile
you're going to pay attention to what's
going on around you and do your best not
to get does that mean that you will
never get burned no
nothing in life you can't eat food
without the possibility that you could
choke you can't drink water without the
possibility that you could cough up get
get something caught down there
every single circumstance that you get
get in a pool
every everything that you think of in
life me getting from this table and
walking down to my car i could slip
everything has risk involved okay
so this attitude of doomsday when it
comes to relationships is gonna bury you
it will bury you before you've had the
chance to to have a successful
fulfilling rewarding relationship don't
take the bait
make better choices
okay go out on several dates get to know
somebody get to know their family get to
know how they treat their friends get to
know their circle take your time
have good conversations really know the
person that you're investing in so that
you're not sitting worrying that they're
gonna take this imagine going into a
marriage well they're gonna take this
from me if it ever ends
first of all you won't sleep
you won't have good sex because you'll
be distrusting that person
it's just not a recipe for success so
again
things are broken you have the power to
do better to fix them not everybody is
operating like it's doomsday from day
one or they wouldn't they wouldn't
bother no one would be married
people are married and they're happily
married and you can be too but you can't
have this attitude on day one that
doesn't mean don't be smart that doesn't
mean if there's a girl that's like oh i
want a sugar daddy you run up and you no
be smart
okay but you can still be smart
and live life
okay if you like the short clip you can
catch another one here or you can catch
the full episode
right here
[Music]